okay this next story is so damn funny
that it's actually difficult for me to
put into words marianne williamson is
running for the 2020 Democratic
presidential nomination she has no
chance I mean she's polling so low that
she's not even in the top 20 candidates
in recent polling summaries now she's a
little bit wacky she has a long history
of being a sort of New Age self-help
guru I've interviewed her on the program
before but she also has lots of
completely reasonable and and mainstream
left-wing views which I agree with and
many of the people in our audience would
agree with there is also a cultural
critic and arbiter of Big Ideas named
Dave Rubin who is all about discussing
ideas and he's like a sort of
center-right kind of guy and he
interviewed Marianne Williamson and she
truly made him look so uninformed and
did it so easily like without even
breaking a sweat with no visible effort
debunking all of Dave Reubens attempts
to put her in some sort of current
corner and it was really a pleasure to
watch so I want to look at a couple of
these with you one popular sort of uh
meme or false notion that the right has
been pushing is that we should be giving
Donald Trump credit because he decided
not to bomb Iran and it's such a dumb
talking point because if it ignores the
reality that Trump is the one who made
the decision to bomb Iran in the first
place and then he erratically canceled
it last minute after someone said hey
you know 150 people are likely to die
because of this right and Bernie Sanders
had a really good analogy on this when
he was asked shouldn't Trump get credit
for not bombing Iran but Bernie said
this is like if you set a trashcan on
fire and then you put the fire out and
you say hey everybody I did a great
thing
I put the trashcan fire out it's like
well you set the fire in the first place
so what kind of credit do you really
deserve for that so marianne williamson
destroys this talking point easily
points out that Trump is pulling us from
the nuclear deal that Trump's pulling us
from the nuclear deal better said was
the real problem I know you wouldn't
want to give it to him but does Trump
deserve some credit for not doing that
strike if you get it you got a call a
minute before and
credit in terms of Iran no it was the
president who got who recklessly removed
us from the Iran nuclear deal that is
what led up to that the president taking
us out of the Iran nuclear deal out of a
situation that was an international
leveraging where by all indicators Iran
was that we know of the Iran was
compliant so now they've said the other
day that they're going to go on and
enriched uranium beyond what the
agreement called for because we had
pulled out no I cannot give the
president any credit for what's
happening with Iran the fact that he was
about to do something so unbelievably
reckless because let me tell you
something given the size of the Iranian
army alone you think Iraq was a
catastrophe nothing compared to what war
with Iran would look like so obviously
some hero we don't know exactly who it
was but we know someone within the
higher echelons of either his
administration is national security
apparatus or the military talked them
out of it that we can be very thankful
to this person whoever they were this is
really fun I have to admit I love
watching these clips it's just so so
funny to watch the breakdown because
you've got kooky Marianne Williamson
just easily exposing the absurdity of
these questions from Dave Rubin so
here's another one another one of these
ideas that sort of being pushed on
Democrats is the idea that the
Democratic 2020 presidential candidates
are for open borders and of course not a
single Democrat has said anything about
open borders and this is so funny
because when marianne williamson points
it out Dave Rubin says well okay they're
not saying they're for open borders but
it sort of seems like that's what their
policies are all about and marianne
williamson is just having none of it
okay a couple more quick we'll try to do
them quick it seems like everyone's kind
of veering to some version of open
borders that's I've not heard one
candidate well they want to say but the
policies oh you don't say it but you
really mean ways is that is that healthy
honorable debate of course no one has
said anything about open borders
policies and this is actually what they
say we're not supposed to do when it
comes to saying people are racist except
here it's really a cut and dry policy
thing so let me explain what I mean by
that the right loves to say even if
someone says something that sounds
racially insensitive or it could be
xenophobic or racist you don't really
know what's in their mind so you can't
call them racist you don't know their
true motivations for saying that thing
that might sound racist so you shouldn't
call them racist here Dave Rubin is
saying okay even though no one has
actually said they want open borders
it's okay to infer that they're for open
borders apparently because what they're
against caging kids at the border
they're against deporting daca
recipients who were brought to the
United States by their parents through
no fault of their own when they were
minors and then lastly
Dave Rubin tries to I guess call out
marianne williamson for making an
analogy between the holocaust and
slavery in the united states as horrible
horrible events which is funny because
the right claims to be against the
oppression Olympics this is one of their
big things the right says you know I'm
against ranking oppressive events I'm
against ranking what group what
demographic group is more or less
oppressed or deserving of help in
society okay fine
but here is marianne williamson who
seems to have to explain that to dave
rubin
well well do you think there's a little
bit of a risk in sort of yeah i mean a
couple of times you're referencing the
genocide of the Jews to slavery seems
like a little bit of a slippery slope
there now I don't even know how we can
say that actually and I say that as a
Jew if you read up much on slavery
yeah we're talking object slavery day I
mean nobody's in a contest nobody has a
monopoly on human suffering
this was object slavery there's always a
risk
equating civil rights catastrophes
because it's true there's no two events
that are exactly the same events take
places events take place in different
places and at different times in history
so to say two events are the same or
basically the same or mean the same
thing it's a little bit risky but
American slavery was one of the worst
thing that's happened and the Holocaust
is one of the worst things that has
happened in human history on this planet
so this may have been like the best
possible thing to ever happen to Mary
Ann Williams since Campaign she's still
polling at zero and it doesn't even seem
like that many people have seen this
interview but it was really a pleasure
to watch and I got some emails after the
last debate this this is really weird
after the the democratic debate a few
weeks ago I got some emails from people
saying hey David
I think Marianne Williamson actually did
the best in the debate I think Marianne
won the debate
here's links to some youtubers who agree
with me and I was certain it had to be
some kind of satirical thing like back
when Howard Stern's audience was trying
to vote for Sanjaya a candidate on
American Idol even though the kid
couldn't sing just because it would be
funny to support someone who has no idea
what's going on but apparently it was
real and a lot of people actually seem
to be claiming that in syria's in some
kind of serious way marianne williamson
won that first debate
she holds some of the right positions on
a number of issues but she is quite out
there and certainly not somebody I could
see getting behind given the other
people that are in the 2020 Democratic
slate of possibilities let me know what
you think make sure you're following me
on instagram at david pakman and while
you're there
follow the david pakman show on
instagram at david pakman show right
back after this today's program is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman if you've not already heard about
blinka it's amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
fifteen minute audio book you get all
the most important information and
insights from each book but you can soak
up the entire essence
of the book in one sitting I've listened
to a ton of books on blinken recent one
is a Robert Rice's new book the common
good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink as comm slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n